vamos ahora al problema 135 135 vengo
con mucha energía porque acabo de hacer
pilates lo cual estuvo padrísimo pero
bueno y después te cuento más de mi vida
personal ahorita vamos a hacer este
problema dice si x es menor que cero si
x es menor que cero la pregunta es que
será mayor que cero y será mayor que
cero muy bien vamos a ver qué
información tenemos en el inciso 1 en el
inciso 1 la información que nos dan es
que x entre y x entre i es menor que
cero está bien esta información de aquí
está muy buena para responder la
pregunta verdad porque pensemos tantito
qué sucede aquí tenemos que x es un
número negativo es un número negativo lo
estamos dividiendo entre algo que no
conocemos pero nos queda algo negativo
nos queda algo menor que cero esto es
igual a algo negativo entonces que
podemos poner aquí abajo si ponemos algo
negativo entonces nos quedaría negativo
/ negativo lo cual sería positivo verdad
y eso de allí pues sería falso porque
aquí dice que es negativo si aquí abajo
ponemos un cero la división quedaría
indefinida entonces no podemos hacer eso
de modo que la única posibilidad de
exponer aquí algo positivo simplemente
por leyes de signo en la división verdad
para que negativo entre positivo nos
queda igual a negativo entonces tuvimos
que dividir entre algo positivo es decir
que es mayor es mayor que cero sale
entonces esta de aquí si nos permite
responder y ahora vamos a ver qué nos
dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos
dicen que menos x es mayor que 0 es
mayor que 0 esto sumando x de ambos
lados
simplemente nos dice que es mayor que x
que ya es mayor que x y sabemos que x es
menor que cero entonces en realidad aquí
no sabemos gran cosa verdad o sea x
puede ser digamos menos uno y ya puede
ser no sé a lo mejor
- 0.5 y en este caso es más dejando
poner un ejemplo todavía más claro que
podría hacer vamos a borrar esto x
podría ser igual a menos 10 y igual a
menos 9 en cuyo caso ya le gana x pero
ya es negativo o bien que podría ser
igual a 9 y 9 también le gana menos 10 y
en este caso ya que da positivo entonces
esto de aquí no es información
suficiente para responder esta pregunta
de modo que la respuesta sería a saleh
la respuesta es a vamos ahora al
problema 136 problemas 136 aquí nos pone
en un dibujo déjame hacerlo es un es un
círculo un círculo más o menos así donde
además bueno por aquí está el centro más
o menos imagínate que es el centro nos
marcan este radio nos marcan este radio
este de aquí se llama y aquí dice que es
ángulo recto en este punto es x
este punto de acá desde este punto de
acá es zeta ceta muy bien creo que es
todo
ajá no también está marcado ha marcado
este lado de acá va entonces a partir de
este dibujo nos preguntan cuál es la
circunferencia o el perímetro de este
círculo de aquí con centro entonces lo
que necesitamos es determinar el
perímetro
metro
muy bien vamos a ver qué información nos
dan inciso 1 en el inciso 1 nos dicen
que el perímetro del triángulo
x z es 2010 raíz de 2 el perímetro del
triángulo o x z es igual a 2020 + 10
raíz de 2 a ver vamos a ver si esto de
aquí es suficiente déjame ponerle un
cierto nombre al radio de la
circunferencia digamos x igual a r como
x es un radio y/o z también es un radio
entonces z vale r y como aquí tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo podemos utilizar el
teorema de pitágoras para ver cuánto
mide este lado x z al cuadrado es igual
a r al cuadrado más r al cuadrado
es más real cuadrado que es igual a 2 r
al cuadrado
de modo que x zeta esta longitud es
igual a raíz de 2 x r vale con eso
tenemos la información de este lado este
lado y este lado en términos de r y lo
que nos están diciendo aquí entonces es
que el más r más raíz de 12 r raíz de 2
r es igual a 20 más 10 raíz de 2 a ver
de este lado lo puedo poner como 2 r más
raíz de 2 r es igual a 20 más 10 raíz de
12 y aquí podríamos factorizar la r y
luego pasar dividiendo o bien darnos
cuenta que era igual a 10 funciona vale
si ponemos era igual a 10 nos queda aquí
20 y aquí nos queda 10 raíz de 2
entonces con esto tenemos que r es igual
a 10 y por supuesto conociendo el radio
de una circunferencia podemos determinar
su perímetro entonces este de acá es
para responder la pregunta vamos a ver
ahora qué nos dicen que nos dice el
inciso 2 voy a cambiar de color de verde
este es un poquito más oscuro
entonces el inciso 2 dice que la
longitud de arco del arco x y z es 5 pi
le voy a poner así este la longitud de x
y z del arco x y z así
un poco más curvado ándale es igual a 5
a 5
ok entonces el arco x y z es este de acá
y nos dicen que su longitud de arco es
55 pi
pero esto justo es un cuarto de la
circunferencia porque está siendo
abierto por un ángulo de 90 grados
entonces sabiendo que esto mide 5 y
tendríamos que el perímetro es 4 veces
eso sería igual a 20 mil vale entonces
el inciso 2 también nos permite
responder la pregunta de modo que la
respuesta sería b
de cualquiera de los dos incisos nos
permite responder la pregunta muy bien
ahora vamos al inciso ahora vamos al
problema más bien 137-137 voy a bajar un
poco más para tener más espacio en el
problema 137 lo que nos preguntan es
determinar el valor de a la cuarta menos
b a la cuarta cuánto es a la cuarta
menos b a la cuarta seguramente antes de
ver las opciones sería una buena idea
factorizar esto voy a poner a la cuarta
menos b a la cuarta y esto de aquí es
igual a esto es una diferencia de
cuadrados en donde es decir tenemos algo
del estilo x al cuadrado menos llega al
cuadrado donde x es igual a al cuadrado
y que es igual a b al cuadrado sale el
entonces esto de aquí sería
al cuadrado al cuadrado menos b al
cuadrado al cuadrado y esta sabemos
factorizar la así como este menos este a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada x este más
este x a cuadrado más b cuadrada vale y
aquí volvemos a tener otra diferencia de
cuadrados esto de aquí es igual a a
menos ve a menos b por hamás ve por más
b por a cuadra damas b cuadrada este
término de acá
+ b cuadrado bueno vamos a ver si esto
ayuda de algo veamos las opciones en el
inciso 1 lo que nos dicen es que a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada menos b
cuadrada es igual a 16 es igual a 16 ok
entonces lo que nos están dando es este
término de acá déjame tomar otro color
este es igual a este de acá
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué nos dice
el inciso 2 del inciso 2
porque estoy aquí no es suficiente
verdad todavía quién sabe que sea a
cuadrada más ve cuadrada entonces si
queremos responder esta pregunta el
inciso 1 no va a ser suficiente y por
eso ya me pase al 2 en el inciso 2 lo
que nos dicen es que a más b
es igual a 8 ok esto está interesante
entonces tenemos este y este pero éste
ya estaba en este de acá a mira vamos a
hacerle así nos dicen que además b es
igual a 8 y nos dicen que a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada es igual a 16 pero a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada es a más b
por a menos
sale y nos están diciendo con esta
información que es igual a 16 y nos
están diciendo que este cachito de acá
además ve es igual a 8 entonces podemos
dividir entre 8 de ambos lados para
obtener que que
b es igual a 16 entre 8 es decir 2 y
teniendo que ambas veces 8 y que a menos
de estos pues claramente podemos
determinar los valores de a idv y con
eso determinar el valor de aa la cuarta
menos b a la cuarta es más déjame
hacerlo si tenemos estas dos podemos
sumar las de modo que nos quedaría que
dos a la vez se cancela con la b es
igual a 10 así que es igual a 5 y
entonces como a más veces 8 tenemos que
ver es igual es igual
a 3 y la resta dados ok y ya con los
valores de ahí debe pues pudiéramos
obtener el resultado verdad simplemente
tenemos que a la cuarta menos b a la
cuarta es igual a 5 a la cuarta menos 3
a la cuarta pero esto ya no lo voy a
hacer insisto sería una pérdida de
tiempo al llegar a este punto ya
deberíamos determinar automáticamente
que la información que tenemos la de los
dos incisos es suficiente para responder
el problema bueno entonces la respuesta
sería c cada uno de los incisos por
separado no nos permite responder esta
pregunta pero si los juntamos sí